[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong I am your host
Mark Ellis joined as always by my trusty
cohort the the Wednesday to my Pugsley
jacqulyn Coley how are we on this fine
Halloween into Thanksgiving holiday
transitioning day I think this is a
great time this is where fall really
kicks in this is my favorite time I know
a lot of people love Halloween and I
like Halloween fine but I'm a
Thanksgiving girl an entire day built
around food and football but mostly food
I'm sorry the football is there and I
love football as well but like now we I
would still enjoy the day even if the
football wasn't there but if you remove
the food I would die now Thanksgiving I
would say probably up there it it's been
my favorite holiday different parts of
my life and I love that time of the year
most if I could just take that like
September weather and put it into
November cuz it it's getting a little
chilly
Mar now my it start I got the skin
starting to jaap a little bit uh let's
bring in our special guest here you know
her as third of the World Girls uh
darina Ariano you know her you love her
returning favorite here on the show
darina your favorite time of year is
Halloween
okay good way I like Halloween I'm just
not with the when people say I love how
it's a different gear than me and I
don't play when that same gear so I have
to be very clear I am like a casual on
Halloween this is a professional correct
I am a professional and uh I also
understand the appeal of the food and
the football day that is it is also a
fantastic day um I like it much more
than Christmas but um Halloween is you
know it I celebrated it for two months
about September October because if
Christmas gets two months why doesn't
Halloween right so uh the only uh issue
now is that that this is when the
seasonal depression starts oh what is
that D yes is that a thing thing with
you or is that a thing with just the
populace in general is there some sort
of Planet that's spinning the wrong way
this time of year that causes this
there's always a spined a spin it a plan
there's always a spin it there's always
a planet spinning the wrong way but it's
sunny all the time except for soon the
winter time that makes me sad I don't
like are we changing the time again I
don't want to do that I don't know when
we roll the clocks back to and fro but I
know that the clocks are always right
twice a day except maybe if you're in
The Adams Family Residence cuz know
those clocks ever work on time or maybe
those are the only clocks that actually
are really telling the time the way it
should be because we know the adamses
we've loved them since some folks from
as far back as the sitcom in the 60s and
then you had these two movies that
dropped in the early 90s he had Adams
Family 91 Adams Family Values in 1993
which is the topic of our conversation
today shout out to our crew over at
Rotten tomatoes.com you can currently
find the best 60 Thanksgiving movies
over there Charlie Chaplan in the Gold
Rush is number one at 100% welld
deserved Adams Family Values is number
18 on this list sporting a
75% certified fresh score 63% with the
audience which is still fresh but a
little I I think I have a feeling why
it's a little lower for some audience
members uh the OG Adams Family from 1991
the OG movie I should say is 67% fresh
with a 66% audience score so we have
these movies that we love for Halloween
we have Christmas movies and this one is
for many reasons I think considered
rightfully so a Thanksgiving film maybe
the best Thanksgiving movie of them all
before we find out what our take on
Adam's Family Values is some 30 years
after its release and I saw this in
theaters oh my God what's happening to
me let's go to you first darina our
special esteemed guest I feel like a
movie and a guest have never been more
perfectly paired on this show than
Adam's family values and darina being
our special guest is Rotten Tomatoes
wrong about Adam's Family Values this is
a much too low score this is too low
this is if you can uh if some of the
sequels and prequels of the Star Wars
franchise are at 90s or 80s it is much
too low this movie is better than any
anything that those people made just
saying wow yeah know this this is a and
we all love the first one here we're all
huge fans of the first onut uh but the
second one to me is even better it is a
masterpiece of a movie it is got it's
got not only probably the greatest
casting ever um you got a A bodiqua
Gomez with the great ra Julia being his
last movie um you got obviously the
great Angelica Houston Christina Richie
um and on top of that it's visually
stunning and one of the greatest
villains of all time with the great Jon
kek as deie jalinski like this is a
perfect Almost Perfect movie like I
maybe you could give it like a 90
something percent Maybe but I don't
really see any flaws in it I could I I
think Rotten Tomatoes is wrong because
it's too low and the audience score I
don't think they understood it for it
being 60 something I think that there
was some uh some Panic going on with
some parents is is maybe what I would
say is why the audience as low as it is
because I agree with you I think this
movie you'd it'd be a raging debate in
my household which is pretty much just
me and the dog barking at each other as
the whether the first one or the second
one is is the better film the first
Adams to the second because I could
watch these as long movie like they're
that good and everybody comes to play in
both there's nobody who is great in the
first one who's mailed in in the second
one I love love love both of these
movies and they present a sense of humor
that I think is sorely lacking in cinema
that we've gotten today like there's
been great comedies that come up every
so often but my God these things are
just every joke hit in these films so
hard Jaclyn Coley are you in agreement
with this Love Fest or is Rotten
Tomatoes maybe a little wrong on the
other side for you it's it's
you know what did we just win you over
already before the movie talk segment
began I just think the audience score is
more right I think the audience score is
right I don't think that the film's
issues are specifically related to what
was seen on screen I think this is a
case of the same reason why Skyfall if
you look at that movie it has a much
lower score than the other ones it's
because they made James Bond fallible
it's because people don't want to see
James Bond get hurt want to see James
Bond be the toughest dude on the Block
it's wish fulfillment you don't want to
see The Adams Family get too close to
normal the closer they get to normal and
this was an instance where it's like
before it was the weirds Adams Family
where normal was just sort of peeking on
the outside trying to invade them now
you have the different situation of like
no we have taken the weird and put it in
the normal and it just doesn't sit well
to me you know what I mean like like I
en I enjoyed the place that they took
these characters but in the back of my
mind I was like I don't think we should
be here huh like we we went we went
wrong to be here and don't get me wrong
I know why we went wrong because they
wanted to set up what they set up which
was amazing but it's like we sacrificed
I think a lot especially with the other
characters like Gomez and um mortia
mortia spend most of the time in that
Motel doing absolutely nothing do you
know what I mean like it's like they
kind of condense down their story in a
lot of ways what are you talking about
not doing nothing not doing nothing what
are you talking about like they're you
you just called out the uh the most
romantic beautiful cou fictional couple
maybe the greatest that has the sexiest
consensual BDSM
sex they are not doing nothing in that
Motel no you're right you're very true
in that respect it I I wanted to be very
the minute it came out of my mouth I was
like well not nothing but do you know
what I mean like when we talk about the
plots and the moments that work on this
movie it's a Wednesday Adam movie and a
Joan Cusack movie and an uncle Fest yes
movie and all of those things make it
absolutely incredible they're the
favorites and some of the best parts of
the first movie so I get why we're
leaning in that being said I'm like
could we have found another way well you
have the privilege and by the way you
should know that maybe of everybody here
on the show today the biggest lover of
Adams Family Values in the room might be
producer Brian because Dar said it's one
of her favorite movies of all time Brian
immediately jumped in yeah unprovoked he
doesn't say a lot folks wedged into the
conversation but he had to make his
presence known about this one he loves
this movie which Jacqueline is now going
to give us the synopsis of Adam's Family
Values I really do feel bad because I
feel if I get one word wrong she's going
to come across this sure microphone and
turn it over to no I got it I got it but
I'm I'm just letting you know that I
would never stab you Jacqueline I
secretly poison you I'm kidding I might
deserve it uh so we find ourselves back
with The Adams Family as mortia let us
know in the previous one we're going to
be having new addition obviously to the
family and he needs a nanny um we have
the youngest Adam's family needs a nanny
and so they hire the very beautiful the
very bright and the slightly weird Joan
cusac who plays Debbie gillinsky and she
immediately develops a love affair with
Uncle Fester and we find out later that
is because Debbie is a severely deranged
serial killer who marries uh wealthy
lonely men so that she can steal their
inheritances and that's essentially what
ends up doing to The Adams Family First
she kicks out his family gets all the
funds under Uncle Fester tries to doll
him up into this weird version of
himself good with a very bad wig and
meanwhile the kids are shipped off to a
summer camp full of the worst versions
of Karen's and Chads that you have ever
seen and meanwhile mortia and the rest
of the crew including granny thing and
Lurch and everyone else is stuck in a
motel which is the only place that they
can afford in their very
stunted uh Financial circumstances no
that's the first one oh does oh wait no
once they get kicked out of the manor
the girls are on at the Thanksgiving
sort of like they're at the summer camp
and they put on a Thanksgiving play
where Wednesday falls in love and
Pugsley and them are literally just the
worst versions they don't smile the
Karen and the Chad who run it played by
the great Christine baransky and Peter
McNichols who you recognized some
Ghostbusters anyway they're not having
it they basically set the entire camp on
fire this is around the time that Debbie
is trying to enact her final plan but
meanwhile everybody gathers together
they stop Debbie they bring back
everyone and fester of course reconciles
with his brother and they all find out
that it's all good because Debbie
obviously Twisted them against it and
they all live happily ever after yeah
they do everybody does the one thing I
got wrong you know what it was we were
thinking about the damn Motel before we
were talking about the BDSM sex it's
confusing because of of the it's there's
similar plot lines similar plines but no
they don't get don't get sent over to
the motel room in this one honestly I
just wanted to think about their BDSM
sex but that ladies and gentlemen is The
Adams Family I mean you have the first
movie where it's kind of like just
trying to welcome Fester back into the
family and then here it's Fester you
know against his own will sort of
locking them out then so there's a lot
of festering going on there a lot of the
first one and in Adams Family Values
which now we're going to turn it over to
our buddy Tim Ryan who is our expert
review curation manager here at Rotten
Tomatoes he's going to tell us what
critics were saying at the time of this
film's release when a 12-year-old Mark
Ellis might have gone with a bunch of
his friends to see this very film two
minutes with Tim two minutes with it's
not a hard and fast rule by any means
but the general trajectory of most
franchises is as follows the first entry
is a critical and Commercial hit and the
sequels clean up at the box office while
receiving a more muted response from the
critics obviously there are exceptions
and one of the more perplexing is the
case of The Adams Family films the Adams
family from 1991 was a box office smash
cracking the top 10 in a year that
included the likes of Terminator 2 home
alone and Silence of the Lambs the
sequel Adams Family Values found favor
with the critics who enjoyed its Sly
satire of contemporary politics and the
performances particularly from Angelica
Houston rul Julia and especially
Christina RI but while it's become a
cult favorite in the ensuing years its
reputation greater than the original
Adam family values barely cracked the
top 30 at the box office in 1993 taking
in half of what the original made Adams
Family Values is certified fresh at 75%
on the Tomato Meter with 114 reviews and
it has a 63% audience score and just for
comparison The Adams Family from 1991 is
fresh at 67% so what did the critics
have to say in a fresh review Dan gy of
the Chicago Daily Herald wrote as she
was in the first Adams Family film
Richie Wednesday is the glowing Ember of
the cast a dead pan dead on deadly
deliverer of devilishly devastating
dialogue however in a rotten review Gary
Thompson of the Philadelphia Daily News
wrote though this sequel probably has
more creative energy than its
predecessor the constant stream of on
liners and site gags is very much hit or
miss the Rotten Tomatoes critics
consensus reads new well-developed
characters add Dimension to this baddy
satire creating a comedy much more
substantial than original so that's
Adam's Family Values let's Ki it back to
Jacqueline and Mark two people who
gladly Feast on those who would subdue
them that was beautiful I needed I need
a little bit more sauce on that line
retim but I appreciate it I'm just
saying you you got to bring the goods
for that one let's get into this one
because I have a feeling we're I'm gonna
feel like a little bit like you were
last week Mark on this one I mean I'm
just saying the
[Music]
music I can't help but think that one of
the reasons why this one didn't have the
box office returns of the first one even
though it had most of the critical
Acclaim is that Thanksgiving is a time
for food and football but also big- time
movies family kind of movies come out
this movie was released November 19th
1993 and it was number one of the box
office the next week Mrs Doubtfire
showed up and her way to I mean just
demolishing everything else in her path
so darina you're and I were about the
same age maybe a few weeks difference
did we see this movie the theater like I
did oh yes yes um I was about this was
93 correct I was about 11 years old so
still in Mexico and saw it in the Mex
Mexicali theater subtitles and I was
very excited because I was always a huge
fan of the first one I had no idea I was
going to love this one even more and I
remember because the there's a huge
difference between um one of the
cultural differences between Mexicans
and American families is there's a
reason why this particular movie would
not be as popular today and would not be
sold as a family film right because of
the two adult sexy humor right so that's
not that's not something that happens in
Mexico right like for us where like
there's we kids are aware that sex
exists right here they they try to
Shield it from you right so we cleverly
like basically it's just not upfront
like they put it in there but it's only
the adults get it correct yes and so uh
so that was uh anything any of the dark
humor was great like we loved all of it
right like it was it was a right at the
entire theater was laughing and clapping
like it was it was very well received
when when I saw it uh it was yeah it
it's uh I was very happy with it I was
obsessed with it uh I told my mom this
is my favorite Thanksgiving movie uh no
offense to the great Steve Martin and
John Candy obviously because that's the
other very was pretty good Thanksgiving
movie yeah did you did either of y'all
because we like I knew what the Adams
Family was from seeing it on TV
constantly was that in everybody's house
or just mine the original sitcom the
black and white yes that was on that was
nighter or somewhere in there but we all
knew it we all knew the character so
like walking into the first one cuz I
saw both of these movies in the theater
when I was a kid and seeing this one in
Williamsburg Virginia it just again you
walked out of the theater just marveling
at how many jokes how fast and and I
really left thinking that Joan cusc was
such a surprising and awesome and
hilarious and nefarious villain like she
really shows up and you don't know what
to make of her initially and quickly you
realize she is the antagonist in this
movie and I just thought she just
knocked it out of the stadium so
completely the best scene actually my
favorite scene in the movie is when she
blows up or thinks she blows up fester
in the house and she's outside in her
car and she starts practicing how she's
going to cry in front of the cops right
and she starts uh doing her little and
then she
goes like that evil laughter transition
it's incredible like not a lot of actors
can do that she's this before where she
tries to to electrocute fester in the
bathtub and and he just and then we see
the classic Fester with the light like
it's just so much great is in this movie
jacqu did you see in the theater or was
this were you a late arrival to Adams
Family Values I'm pretty sure I saw
Adam's family in the dollar theater at
the Sunrise Mall shout out to Corpus
Christie I think this was a TNT special
for me I think this one was definitely
on TV it was definitely on TNT because I
I want to be clear I was an only child
so like before I I was of driving age
any movies I wanted to see I had to be
taken to you know what I mean and I was
definitely not taken to the mall until I
was in my Lake but once I was able to
get to the mall on my own yeah I was
there all the time I loved what this
movie did because the first one sets up
Gomez and mortia so well and and like
you said darina this was the last film
that I guess Ral Julia got to see
released because he did Street Fighter
didn't come out till after he had
already passed away and he he I think he
died in in 1994 so you know months after
this movie came out but because that
first one set such a great foundation
for Who The Matriarch and the patriarch
are I think that they also like the
filmmakers Barry sonnenfeld and Company
you go back and you watch that first one
you say we really got some gold with
these kids yeah with with with pugsy
particularly Wednesday like this
Christina RI is not just a good like kid
act this is a star and so I think they
took that and ran with it for Adams
Family Values and I love that she got
more of more to do and boy did she step
up and knock it out of the park totally
and especially because I think the
reason I love the you just said it the
first one was more of a focus on the the
adult relationship right the second one
they give him a little baby they give
him a little pubert right pu fantastic
name
mustach mustach uh but um it makes sense
uh to focus on the kids this time
because the the great thing about these
movies to me is that to me The Adams
Family are the antithesis of a uh you
know the the nuclear American family
with the with the family values right
the Suburban stereotype of what a family
should be right and so I love that's why
I think mortia and Gomez are so amazing
together and and show you what a healthy
Rel loving relationship is um and with
Wednesday um you get you know the what a
teenage girl is going through at that
time and how she feels like an outcast
as uh Jaan beautifully said especially
amongst Karens and Chads seriously
entire of them yeah and and so I just
love the fact that you know like there's
a great line where um the kid that
Wednesday's hanging out with I think his
name is Joel the little Jewish kid and
um and you know he he asks her um what
what have you met the right man who
worshiped you adored you blah blah blah
uh who you know who was your your
devoted slay what would you do and she
goes I'd pity
him I mean but look at the dynamic
between mortia and Gomez like as much as
they become loving you would imagine
that was probably the beginning of their
courtship he's been a s since the
beginning and she's basically like maybe
you know what I mean like the men are
seem to be under the spell of women
which is not just Central to The Adams
Family i' say that's whether most dudes
want to admit it or not an but it's not
like a like usual sitcoms for example
right like like the sitcoms you're used
to like married with children or things
like that usually the guy is always
crapping on the wife I would say Married
with Children I I'm going more
traditional like you know a more family
sitcoms like Harriet type stuff I I I
would look at this is like According to
Jim you know cuz like Jim is
just and that kind of stuff like King of
Queens things like that Everybody Loves
Raymond right and that's honestly like
just with all the relationships I've had
with the fair sex it's like that's
pretty much how it goes it's like you
just show up and like hey how can I do
you know today how can I earn enough how
can I do boyfriend for my reward good
boyfriend so I can go drink it with the
boys on on night s is that what your
reward is no I think every guy starts
the day of like how nice do I have to be
to her so I can continue to be laid by
the end of this evening that's also and
it seems to be something that mortia and
Gomez celebrate regularly and and the
relationship like it's so tough to to
narrow down like who's your favorite
member of this household you know but I
was just this on this rewatch I was so
struck by how great Christopher Lloyd is
and just disappearing into the role of
fer he he completely you know it's
Christopher Lloyd but every every look
every gesture every line is so well
crafted and it starts right at the
beginning of the movie when he say
howling at the moon I mean this thing
sets you up for exactly what it is
before the the credits rule we see
fester and despair we see the birth of
pubert and then we're just we're right
into it I also think it was really
interesting is everybody in here is
giving performance art everybody's in
drag everybody like this is a movie like
I don't want to like speculate on Barry
sonnenfeld's sexuality or the sexuality
of the writer production designer anyone
but this is just a movie that feels like
it was like made by like sassy Camp be
gays and theater kids like I'm sorry
you're getting like all these like
lowkey theater Idols like Christine
baransky like Joan Cusack like Tony
shaloo David Hyde Pierce Nathan freaking
lame you know what I mean I'm like there
are some there are some gays with like
yes fabulous darling with the lights in
the hair we're going to like I feel it
in the DNA of this movie too much to
where it's like if you don't get that
aspect of it that's the part that I love
the most but that's the thing that like
Starks so hardly against the like stotch
like like J crew lands n like GH waspy
Connecticut BS like every time I think
about it I'm just like why are you here
when you line up Pugsley and Wednesday
at the summer camp at uh good old camp
chipa Camp chipa right next to all those
other kids and the way they look it's
you can't help but pull for the the
weird kids for the for the the and and
I'd lock Joel in there too played by
David kumel where it's like yeah I love
that they found another Outcast I I
thought that was really important to
this movie where it's not just us and
our little family against the world
there are other people like the Adams's
out maybe not to that that Extreme as
far as their living quarters but there's
people who have a different way that
they look at society and the fact that
the Adams found somebody not in their
family I think was really special and a
Lynch pin of this movie totally and um I
think that that that's honestly the
biggest reason why I like this movie is
uh because it's showing this family that
like you said goes into this Camp these
kids that are complete outcasts for the
wrong reasons right it's not just
because they're weirdos the Adam's
family are supposed to be weirdos that
people are like oh they're they wear
black and they like spiders and like you
know they're just I don't get it they're
probably satanic you know like whatever
some Karen would say right no offense to
cool Kens but U but the when they're in
the camp you know um all of these people
are wealthy you know uh weird people
that don't like anybody that's not like
them yeah right and they're actually
discriminatory against anybody that's
not like them it's white supremacy camp
like just go ahead and like call it out
for what it is but the thing I think is
so interesting about it is the tribes
that you find as you sort of adopt them
and like look David crotz who plays Joel
the little Jewish kid who's like
worshiping her a part of the Indian crew
as it were that kid very much
exemplifies that cuz look at him by the
end of the movie he is dappered down
with his little like painted on mustache
you know like he is in it he is in it by
the end and I think that's the I don't
know I I have a different fantasy of
where those two end up in 20 years I
just feel like they're living
mortia and Gomez like literally what
does Wednesday become when she matures
past the school girl outfit I I think
she ends up actually uh dating a lot of
people but never getting married and
just going off on her own and that
that's the dream I see for her but um
but I mean the again the best part is
the and the reason why it's the best
Thanksgiving movie is just going back to
that it's and and as Jacqueline said the
musical aspect of it of seeing Pugsley
and that giant turkey
like eat me that's a great scene but
obviously that's the best part of the
movie is Wednesday's famous speech right
uh uh where uh you know you we decided
to scalp you and or for all these
reasons and and we decided to scalp you
and and burn your village to the ground
right like where she talks about
specifically she literally calls out
people like you know I she's dressed as
an a Native American and she's saying
years from now my people will be forced
to live in mobile homes on reservations
your people work will work hard against
and drink highballs like all of that
speech is an incredible speech I I
that's what I post for Thanksgiving
every year because people are like oh
it's like you know a moment to be
thankful I'm like that's great but
here's what really happened and I think
that's that's what makes it a great
movie I I definitely don't disagree with
you on that that's why I like to remove
all of the things about Thanksgiving
besides the meal from it it's just about
my food yeah I I think that in our
modern society you have a a weird
reconciliation with a lot of our
holidays with the origin story of them
anyway you know and and with this I feel
like is somebody should be assigned at
every Thanksgiving table to deliver the
Wednesday atam speech okay let's eat
yeah it's like a land acknowledgement
like we should definitely have this
before we sit down to do this but you
know you think about the relationship
between Wednesday and Joel which is such
a big part of this movie but it's also
he is somebody who's clearly smitten and
under the spell I I guess you could say
like he really has feelings for this
girl and then you have fester and Debbie
because Debbie shows up and we all know
she's up to something pretty soon after
she arrives but how is Fester supposed
to like I feel so bad for him because
he's just having his Joel moment and we
want Joel and Wednesday to stay together
because we know Wednesday is like a
genuine person but we like we're rooting
for fester to get something but oh no
now Debbie shows up and it's almost like
you see how easy it is and it's like no
it's not supposed to be that easy to
fall in love to meet your soulmate it's
supposed to be hard like what Wednesday
is putting Joel through it should not be
so easy that the nanny shows up in the
next day she's just throw herself at you
she's in love also I might add I still
think it's so funny like the concept of
Thanksgiving as is so Illustrated in
this movie The reason why they needed to
Thanksgiving is because these white
people came over the water completely
ill-prepared like they got here and they
were like you need to bathe and build
things like let's give you some food
crazy people because clearly you do not
understand that like you should die for
not for not taking care of yourself it
that that's the comedy of all of this
but again which ones got called
Savages
yeah when you look at the movie itself
and like and its release and its
reception I I feel like everything is
pretty properly rated I just think that
nobody could can really tell especially
with a comedy when it's released it's
really funny in the moment and then you
go back and you revisit it you know you
watch something like like Porky 10 20
years later and you're like ah maybe
that doesn't all hold up everything
about Adam's family there wasn't
anything that didn't work as well as it
did 93 some of it even works better
today than it did back in 93 so there's
no way to know that you're making a
comedy that's going to stand the test of
time but I feel like really both of
these movies certainly check that box
yeah and I don't know if you guys heard
um that uh apparently so Paul rudnick's
the writer and um and there he took the
name for the film's title Family Value
specifically from a Dan Quail speech
right uh because and Dan Quail was
obviously focused on what I was talking
about earlier I mean he was just using
the southern strategy to win a
republican nomination but yeah basically
thisa he was talking about the LA r
getes
notating the fact that cops keep beating
black people but I'm sure the family is
going to help with that systemic issue
it's like now when you look at like the
game that they played because again
that's the comedy of like now is like
the same game is being played they just
change the players yeah you can you can
do something that is so uh that is such
a has a political message to it that was
so well veiled by The Adams Family where
we're we're receiving all this stuff
even if we just think we're going to see
this kooky campy family live out a day
in their life it's saying the idea
there's different types of families so
they can definitely do it I was going to
ask you this though about it because as
much as is your favorite movie what of
the criticisms that you've heard of it
because I'm sure when you you know
whatever because like again the one that
I have is that it's so funny Jean cisc
said in his revieww that Tim has here
that uh I didn't understand criticism
this is the thing the problem with the
originals we spend too much time in the
mansion and not enough time outside
mixing with regular folk I get what
they're saying their ideas that the
people at the camp are not regular folk
and then any of the stuff with fester
and Debbie is obviously not with regular
folk they actually don't mingle with the
general populace it's very just specific
pockets in various areas but I didn't
understand his review about this one
either but I'm curious what are the
criticism that you've sort of heard
about it when people dislike it um well
Jacqueline you're the first person that
shut up no this is not even the case
this is so not the case um I think um
some of it good joke though seriously I
think some of it is uh some of the stuff
you mentioned that um it got a little
too campy uh but um to me it's just uh
it is what you were saying also earlier
it's it it's it's meant to be more
theatrical to me I mean there's a whole
ass scene with mortia and Gomez dancing
in the middle of a restaurant right and
uh and it's ridiculous but it's so well
shot that to me that is a great U film
making aspect right that I think a lot
of people just sometimes don't
appreciate because they're focused more
on the story and so so um I don't in the
first one as you said there's that great
scene with um uh young the younger
version of uh Amanda the little girl who
plays Amanda who later plays Harmony on
Buffy for all those Buffy fans later
isn't she also the girl that plays the
villain on tro Beverly Hills I think she
is I believe so yeah she's good at those
roles um and uh there's a famous uh Girl
Scout cookie line right in the original
movie where Wednesday says are they made
you know the cookies made of real girl
scouts right and so I feel like that to
me is an a perfect uh joke and example
of what the family is and I feel like
that went to like the 10th degree in the
sequel yeah and so people thought it was
too much right but to me the Adam's
Family finally became the Adam's Family
the first one was like an introduction
kind of like how people hate Man of
Steel but I like it because that's harar
Kent becoming Superman he's not Superman
yet you before they're their full form
before they're their where is the
ultimate form Adam's Family how I see it
it's the the Dragon Ball Z this is their
final form now their power is over 9,000
kind of thing yeah with with this and so
I I can see where it might be like a
little overwhelming for folks but the
thing about this movie too is that it
loses so much momentum if it's not as
funny as it is it is so well written the
jokes are so tight so well delivered you
get like the law of three like bomom
boom and then and then you know you know
the punch is coming like I I there's so
many great lineses that I forgot existed
there's a scene where Fester's just
trying to figure out how to get through
to Debbie and he's talking uh he's in
bed and like Gomez is like tucking his
brother in and Gomez says oh Fester I
just hope one day you'll know the the
the the beauty of having a child and
paying someone else to raise them like
it's just such a good lampooning of
everything modern society is correct
it's just it's such a great uh satire of
uh what Society was then and like you
said even more more so now right like it
I think it's such a good critique of of
the the the fakeness of people trying to
you know have these social constructs
especially around what's family supposed
to be and being like actually that's not
how you are stop faking it everybody's
messed up everybody's weird so stop
judging other people right I feel like
that's the essence of this but also I
mean how can you again not love a movie
J kusek is this amazing villain I I
don't understand the critique because
she's so freaking amazing she's she's so
amazing you can't help it like obviously
when you see her fall in love with her
because she's just this beautiful you
know uh she's going to show up and be
the nanny and then as soon as the turn
happens you you like you sympathize you
don't want Uncle Fester to fall for it
but I mean you're also happy just
because it's so funny get a little bit
of play man he's wearing the wig and
like it's just he's so the wig was so
tragic the wig was so tragic that was a
struggle wig before there were struggle
wigs also let me just go ahead and say
what I think I figured it out Barry son
he's making a John Waters movie without
being John Waters such a good point
that's what this is like I just I feel
like they said we can't hire John Waters
to do this because there's too much
money
involved we got an Oscar winner you know
in Angelica Houston we've got Oscar
nominees and R Julia we've got a lot of
big people that we're bringing into this
we need somebody who can manage kids and
animals and CGI and a whole bunch of
moving parts so like let's get the guy
that did misery let's get the guy that
did you know he's been behind the camera
on some big movies right he knows how to
deliver for this but they said but we
want you to make a John Waters movie
because it is that campy it is that
weird it's very it's very hairspray this
is this is hairspray with different hair
with or it's goth hairspray goth
hairspray goth hairspray ex I've never
thought of that Jac it's a very good
point does that make you like it
more I still like it I just very much
see flaws like like it's just again it's
um I don't want to be one of these
people that gets mad for the movie that
you got cuz I enjoyed the movie that we
got but the reason why I didn't enjoy it
was because of the choice like they made
choices that you can clearly tell were
ba based on focus groups and marketing
and who was the most popular character
at the time because fester and Wednesday
were the most popular characters and I
do feel that like the best part of the
alums family especially the first one is
it felt like an ensemble it felt like
everybody got a moment to shine even
pugs like you know they all had it and
this one is very much not that there's
definitely the first one they're
together all the time as a family and
this one they're each each character is
doing its own thing kind of and even
when they're not together they're doing
things where they both get to have big
moments like Pugsley and Wednesday
playing together it was them playing
together it wasn't necessarily the
singular Wednesday off with her romantic
lead and Pugsley's just there yeah py is
much more like the background dancer
here in this one than he was in the
first one but everybody when they do get
a chance to shine they still do like
Carol Kane um Lurch thing the the
effects on thing still hold up amazing
that was the thing got a lot more to do
obviously in this one uh he was very
much the only one keeping Fester
together but even like Lurch Lurch had
way more to do in the first one again
nothing against everything I like The
Ensemble I think some choices were made
great choices did I enjoy playing in the
land of lens of of Wednesday lighting up
wasp yes would I like to seen every
character get some more stuff like that
what much more all right so here's what
I intimated during the the opening
darina and I want you to help us out
here because again 75% certified fresh
especially for a comedy sequel that's
incredible 63% with the audience score
why do you think the audience not quite
as high on this because everybody like I
talk to just in my real life seems to
think this is the better of the two
that's cuz you have cool friends Mark
like you any theories on why it the
audience is a little cooler on this
movie than the certified fresh Tomato
Meter I think uh family audiences got a
little uncomfortable by being shown the
flaws of the way they live and people
don't like being made it's like I I came
to the theater to have fun and to laugh
and I don't want to think to laugh at
freaks they didn't like it when the
freaks really started to fight back I
specifically it's the fact that the
freaks two of the young freaks are
trying to kill the baby throughout this
movie but it is
hilarious
pubert falling
at Gomez opens a window and wants to see
if it's raining and he catches his kid
lch thing all stepping up knowing that
Wednesday and Pugsley are doing
everything they can to end this kid's
life but it just plays so funny and I
don't think you get away with that in
the first movie because you do have to
fully set up this world and how not just
like they're creepy and they're cooky
but also there is a unique family bond
that they all there is a love there that
they all have and there's this mystical
ability that they all have just to be in
the right place at the right time to
where you can have a lot of knife play
but nobody's really going to get hurt
correct and very
Shakira yes yes yeah and I love that
scene where pubert uh is bouncing off
and ends up on the window of the
airplane as the the are leaving and he
laughs that kid's laugh is so infectious
like I don't know how they managed to
get those filmed the way that they did
but that was like literally one of my
favorite Parts was every time that kid
was like like he's just so happy I'm
sure it was twins that's definitely not
one baby because they need the baby to
work longer so I bet it was twins you
can see so much of Barry sonnenfeld and
and his greatness in this but when you
watch him he directed Men In Black too
so when you watch Men In Black you
really see he's still T some of the best
moments of Men In Black would be right
at home in an Adam family movie you know
like like like watching Vincent denafo
after he gets inhabited by this alien
and just demanding sugar water that that
feels like somebody that just shows up
to the Adams's mansion and gets invited
in but if you look at the between the
two and it should be because look at the
subject matter we're talking about
aliens and a government agency as much
as the camp of that movie is dial down
due to the fact that it's basically X
Files with comedy it's still Hellam it's
still like like Zed and just like you
know the way that they they style
themselves a little bit in that Lind
fantino has the uh the weird Mor like
that that she would be a friend of
mortia or Wednesday whoever I think you
really nailed it he is a Hollywood
approved John Waters onel he really is
um I do want to give a last shout out
again just to mortian and Gomez because
R Julia and Angelica Houston I mean the
entire cast is so great but I don't I
don't know how you find uh new actors to
play those roles with that chemistry
that those two had it is I mean I've
never seen that on screen I I haven't
seen it replicated since it is it is
just incredible and um I miss that like
I we're never going to see that again if
they were a real couple then I would say
okay now I because you know people they
love using that phrase like I'm I'm I'm
I'm ready to meet my person like there's
one person on Earth for I I look at them
and I'm like yeah that there might be
something to that logic when you see how
well they interact now look I I think
that Oscar Isaac and I believe Charlie
theren did the voices for the 2019
animated Adam family I also thought was
great
I haven't seen that one that is rotten
on the Tomato Meter it's like in the 40s
somewhere people hate it I I guess it's
because it's not what we got from the
early 90s although I thought a lot of
that same humor kind of was showcased
are we fans of the Netflix series
Wednesday do we get to check that out I
have only watched one episode of that
and were you did you Mark Ellis it and
what what I say Mark Ellis is like you
didn't really hate it you just stopped
watching it yeah that's basically it I
think I could finish it what happened
for me is I hate when this happens when
I'm I'm watching something and then I
learn something bad about the production
of it that makes me like I I have to
forget that I know certain things about
this one before I go back to watch it
cuz I was in the middle of watching it's
like I don't want to I don't feel good
watching this you know Ian know too much
I know too much yeah uh how do we like
the portrayal of that of your character
Wednesday I thought she was fantastic
it's somebody that uh obviously worships
Christina Richie uh not just as
Wednesday avence but all the way as to
Misty Adams and you know or Misty Adams
U Misty and uh Yellow Jackets um I
thought she's greatest she's so great uh
but Jenna Ortega did a great job um I
think she um as our you know Brian was
saying earlier um she carries the show
yeah I think that that show is not the
show it is without her and and one of
the few times where I'm like she's been
very vocal about that about how much she
had to like fight for that character and
I'm like yeah it makes sense because
everything she said she didn't like was
everything that everybody else didn't
like and it seems like yeah think
somebody that's a fan of the character
who's like literally embodies that
personality quite often in real life I
think she would probably know what the
motivations behind the character are
just a little yeah it seems like Netflix
was trying to do some um you know
teenage like CW meets Harry Potter they
wanted to the Teenage Witch yeah they
wanted to make that they didn't
understand that you know what what the
uh The Adams Family stands for which is
literally you know what's the the famous
uh line uh we Feast on those who would
subdue us yeah right like that's the
whole point of this family so that
that's what needed to be shown I didn't
think the show was bad though I just I
just think she she makes it and it's
it's a really fun show for kids if you
know if you know that you are going in
to see a show that's not really for us
and they still have a lot to do with
that one as far as season two I think
that one will probably lean more into
all the things that you liked right you
you look at these movies and and you
realize you know again Jacqueline kind
of to your point of like you get tired
of watching something you know too much
about how it was made I don't know
everything about how these two movies in
the '90s were made right but I'm you
don't get these movies a lot so that's
why I think it's so cherished and
beloved 30 years later is the fact that
we got these two movies as pure in heart
and soul and comedy as they are there's
something to be cherished because you
don't get a lot of them and the fact
that a comedy sequel can live up to the
first one or even surpass it very very
rare thing to pull off in Hollywood and
Adams Family Value I feel like does it
jacquet is close to there close not just
the just Brian and dar are really
champion in this movie so uh that's
going to do it for a movie talk but now
we're going to transition on over to the
[Music]
mailbag getting a lot of great emails
from you all so you can write us anytime
RT is wrong rotten tomatoes.com that
sound of like there's like business
hours for no you can actually write us
anytime we'll accept your email 247 RT
isong rotten tomatoes.com subscribe rate
review all that good stuff uh Chris
Quarry is writing us today our ketchup
crew member and he says for my money Ace
Ventura when Nature Calls is the
funniest movie ever made I often revisit
the film and laugh my ass off every damn
time hi ho silver away comedy gold I
stumbled upon the Rotten Tomatoes page
for the movie and was pretty surprised
to see it was
21% well not that surprised critics were
pretty brutal to Jim Carrey in the 90s
the movie has a much higher audience
score at 72% but I'd be curious to hear
if I'm alone in thinking that it's still
a tremendously funny movie thanks Chris
well you're talking about comedy sequels
and how hard it is to make a better
comedy than the original I
Chris I appreciate it I felt Ace venturo
when Nature Calls missed the mark when I
saw it in theaters when I was like PE of
my Jim Carrey well probably still
talking like the guy from the first one
I and I couldn't get out of my head I
know there's funny moments in when
Nature Calls but to me I already felt
like Jim cary's just doing an impression
of Ace Ventura and wasn't playing Ace
Ventura but I know a lot of people like
Chris who think when Nature Calls is the
better of the two what say we ladies I
can't remember I know we've done the
first one I think we did the first one
we did the first Pet Detective friend of
the show Steve Burn we have not done the
second one we've not done the second one
21% I don't remember enough about this
one I just remember it being sillier
it's it's more ridiculous it's
definitely better than 21% on the Tomato
are are you when Nature Calls Stan it's
all right I I definitely I love the
first one so much I love Jim Cary so
much I loved him in the in the 90s he
was a crush of mine uh yeah no when
Nature Calls it's fine it's like it's
fine you're like it's it's fine but it's
weird because like Adam's Family Values
it it's almost like again you're just
continuing the movie from the first one
whereas you watch the Power of the of
that first a fentura and how great Jim
Carrey is it's almost like anybody Jim
Carrey anybody else you you can't do
that again yeah that's lightning in a
bottle and even if it's the same guy
playing the same character just a little
different well it's fine because it's
him because he again similar to what we
were saying earlier about Jen Ortega and
when that he carries the movie right
he's so great that I'll watch him do
anything but but you can you know you
can't save a bad story or bad screenplay
right like you can't really no matter
how great of an actor you are how funny
watching him crawl to the butt of a
hippo still pretty still pretty great
like I'm we're very glad oh that's I
remember the white devil yeah white
devil that's what I remember white devil
I do remember that part yeah okay all
right well that's guano bat dong is
guano um darina it's always great saying
you especially this time of year
definitely this is your season girl yes
um uh Jacqueline I'm now passing the
baton to your season oh yeah hope you
all have a lovely Thanksgiving uh I'm
going to be hiding uh and hibernating
for about two months until uh baby Jesus
is born and then I'll come out uh and uh
yeah no thanks for having me guys always
love coming here and um again we will
gladly Feast on those who will subdue us
and y'all did such a great job at uh at
world girls at at covering you know
serious stuff as you need to but then
also just having a good time with the
ladies so world girl seems to be going
strong um anything else you you got you
want to promote uh social media all that
good stuff uh just music I'm working on
I'm scoring some some little films there
so so yeah check out I got my my DJ
website DJ bruha and and you can see all
the scores I've been doing this this
past year uh somebody please hire me to
do a horror movie I would love to
compose that so we had a good time
seeing that John Carpenter a few years
back how good was at the Palladium how
good was that that was that was a great
concert were you at Fantastic did I see
you there yeah we said right yeah I was
to say she's she was down the spooky
part of Austin as well that's what she
does we saw some great movies yeah they
had some great stuff there did you have
any recommendations can be fantastic
Fest or just be in general yes uh my
favorite movie at Fantastic Fest uh when
evil lurks you're the second person to
recommend this everybody about this
movie I got I think it's planned now
it's it's like in theat Nationwide right
I saw it Tiff and it is great I loved it
I loved it it's in theaters now it's
going to be on shutter oh no it's
actually by the time this recording uh
it'll be on shutter by the time it comes
out y yeah it is the I think it's the
best horror movie of the year I've never
seen anything like it and uh I was giddy
in the theater laughing while everybody
else was freaking out even though I was
with a bunch of horror nerds it's really
great it's a really unique taste uh
sorry a unique take on possession okay
I'm in all right that is Dar Ariano you
can check her out across social media
platforms and make sure you do your due
diligence investigate the World Girls uh
uh a out of water their sort of
subset podcast they got a great Empire
going on over there saw I got to hang
out with all three of you at the
Halloween horn that was a lot of fun
making my debut in those mazes yeah um
you can check that out too our on the
street show our Rotten Tomatoes you it's
on social media you follow us on
Instagram all that good stuff you can
actually watch me going through the
mazes and getting the crap scared out of
absolutely terrifying it's all real
folks all genuine reaction so for the
whole gang here at Rotten Tomatoes
that's our esteemed producer Brian Perez
the whole gang that is uh doing all the
tech stuff for us everybody ring to .
for jacine for Dar I am Mark Ellis we
will see yall next time happy
[Music]
[Applause]
holidays